the 94th annual academy awards will take
over hollywood's dolby theater this
sunday and andrew garfield is speaking
out about the lack of nominations for
the massively successful spider-man away
home of course andrew reprised his role
as peter parker alongside his spider
bros tom holland and toby mcguire in the
highest grossing film of 2021 yeah but
the film ended up with just one
nomination for best visual effects now
despite the snubs anders says he
personally feels satisfied because of
the audience response telling the daily
telegraph this
it's the sixth biggest movie in the
history of movies making a film that a
gajillion people want to see together is
a miracle making a film that an awarding
body loves is also a miracle
now andrew is up for the best actor
award for his role as jonathan larson in
tik tik boom he added of this year's
nominees honestly how some people vote
is none of my business i think they
acknowledge some great people but do i
think olivia coleman gave one of the
best performances of the year
yes i do
you know i had an interview once with um
michael douglas we were talking about
ant-man we're talking about black
panther we were talking about marvel
movies and the oscars
and you know i was like i was asking
like what's your take on you know
marvel movies getting nominated for
academy awards like do you think they
should or shouldn't based on whatever
criteria and he goes
they make a bajillion dollars
dude he's like the awards aren't for the
movies that make a bajillion dollars
because in his opinion it was for the
movies that maybe people aren't
necessarily seeing on a grand scale like
a lot of people aren't necessarily
seeing these movies but it's for like a
particular artistic achievement and if
the the body of voters don't think that
a movie reaches you know their level of
artistic you know whatever they're not
voting right oscar voting has been a
controversial thing for a long time now
but i think
to andrew's point and to michael's point
too
sometimes a movie is
it's okay if a movie makes a gajillion
dollars and a lot of people love it
critics and fans don't often agree
anyways no when it comes to mainstream
movies no and i i understand where it
came from was comic book and superhero
movies used to be terrible right and
they just were but then academy
award-winning actors started doing comic
book movies and the bridge never sort of
crossed over where you started getting
incredible writers making incredible
films that were emotional that you know
that you cried during like you can't
tell me on a movie level and this is
where it sort of like gets me not so
much the not so much spider-man but on
an emotional level storytelling level
you can't tell me that like end game
wasn't as impactful as a film than
half of what was nominated at the
academy awards that year and you can't
just pawn it off as being you know a
marvel movie because they've done the
same thing with sci-fi over the years
sci-fi there's been a lot of garbage
sci-fi but sci-fi has got really really
good and there's a lot of crossover
movies and one of the sort of crossover
sci-fi movies that um that i love from
years ago was gattaca with ethan hawke
and to me that movie should have won
everything that year there was no better
movie that yeah but still that sort of
sci-fi fantasy marvel they will just
never be part of that club no matter how
many academy award winners decide to go
and do them you know i don't know about
never i'm not sure about never i you
know
given what i had just said about michael
uh michael douglas's uh opinion and
andrew garfield's idea about spider-man
now at home to your point about
more and more incredibly talented people
writers actors and alike working on
these movies these are the movies that
most people go see
and
i don't think that just because of genre
they won't ever be like in the club so
to speak and i don't think also that it
um validates the movie just to get an
academy award there are plenty of movies
that we love that oh yeah
right academy but i do think that there
will be a point in time
um
when you know the dark knight right
everyone always points to the dark
knight as sort of like that example of
the movie that really did bridge the gap
there
um we'll have more than one and it won't
be like an anomaly i think that that
point is coming i'm i'm not 100 sure
heath ledger would have won let alone
have been nominated had he not passed
away really yeah yeah
because really there's been no one since
that's done something in a sort of comic
book whatever movie and
i don't think that there will be
i don't know man i think we're getting
there you think so i do i really really
do
i think it's like the prevalence of the
kind of creators that are making those
things i think we'll get there yeah all
right now over to is any comments that
you want to read no um i'm looking i'm
looking we have yazzie says i can't
imagine a comic film getting best
picture
but there are always exceptions heath
ledger winning as a joke i think it's
harder to get a best actor best actress
than it is
nomination yeah
i think i think no i think i think for
for like marvel comic book movies i
think maybe you might see something get
a best picture nomination before you
will see one of the leads getting
enacted i think a lot of it has to do
with how the character is written yeah
like the script for that character
because if it's not like
if it's not a phenomenal script if it
serves more like the comic book
trappings of stuff rather than
the character itself that's when you're
not going to get that right but i think
we're moving i think we're moving i mean
yeah anyway
come on and we could get into everything
we can get into who should have been
nominated over the years for the harry
potter movies for sure just based on
performance alone but anyway